hello everyone welcome to today's live
panel discussion promoting reproducible
animal research and journal publications
I am Brenda Kelly Kim labyrinth and I'll
be moderating today's discussion we're
delighted to bring you this panel
discussion presented by ladders the
leading social networking site for
science professionals for more
information please visit us at lab
routes comm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
discussion is designed to be interactive
and we want to hear from you ask
questions you can submit your questions
by typing them in the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking on the green Q&A
button the lower left of the
presentation window will try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or
alternately submit your problems through
the green Q&A button on the lower left I
would now like to introduce today's
speakers Susan Compton and Linda codes
Susan Compton received her PhD in
microbiology from the uniformed services
University of the health science and
completed a postdoctoral fellowship at
the University of Colorado dr. Compton
joined the faculty of the section of
comparative medicine in the Yale
University School of Medicine in 1991
and has been their chief of the
molecular serological and geological
diagnostics unit 1998 susan has also
held several editorial positions within
the American Association for laboratory
animal science and is currently the
associate editor of the journal of the
american association of laboratory
animal science her research is focused
on the diagnosis pathogenesis
transmission and prevention of viral
infections of rodents in particular
coronaviruses parvovirus noroviruses and
most recently astro viruses dr. Todt
received her PhD in pharmacology from
the university of pittsburgh in 1980 and
her DVM degree from Purdue University in
1986
2004 she has held a position of
associate dean of research and faculty
affairs Southern Illinois University
School of Medicine where she is also a
professor in the department of
pharmacology from 2000 from 2002 2006
she was director of the division of
laboratory animal medicine FSI USM she
is also an active member of a al is the
American Association of laboratory
animal science and serves as the
editor-in-chief for that organizations
to peer-reviewed reviewed journals
comparative mixed medicine and the
journal of the american association of
laboratory animal science finally she is
an appointed member of an NIH study
section served on an niehs Advisory
Committee is a steering committee member
and past chair of the group on research
advancement and development of the
Association of American Medical Colleges
and as an advisor to the executive
leadership and academic medicine program
of drexel university dr totes research
interests focus on the genetic
modulations sleep propensity and healthy
and diseased the impact of sleep loss
and diurnal disruption on susceptibility
to and recuperation from infectious and
inflammatory disease and the impact of
environment on research animals and data
I will now turn it over to doctors
confident toes to begin their discussion
thank you all for attending see we have
a reasonably large number of attendees
and Sue and I are going to attempt to
give you our perspective on promoting
reproducible animal research in journal
publications we bring this presentation
to you with the background of over 10
years of experience as journal editors
for a last minute to two journals we
also have been reviewers on many other
journal articles over the course of the
years and we are also functional
scientist so we understand this issue
not only from the
active of journal editors but also from
the perspective of those who are trying
to replicate both our own research and
that that others have published in the
literature so would you like to say a
few words no that pretty much says what
we need to know at this point okay so
we're going to present a little bit of
background by here based on our
perspective and after the quick
presentation then we will take questions
so all questions are welcome please let
us know how we can answer your questions
with regard to reproducible animal
research in perhaps publication in
general in the laboratory animal field
so i would first makes a statement that
as journal editors and as scientists
what we want to do is fundamentally help
communicate our science and make it
better and journals offer a forum in
which both of those activities can take
place not only do we try to publish
sound science but we also try to act as
editors as a feedback opportunity for
authors my personal view is that in many
cases reviewers are viewed as negative
rather than constructive and although
that may seem to be the case
fundamentally it's the author's
responsibility to convince the reviewers
that their work is sound and publishable
and any feedback that comes from
reviewers should be taken in dissent in
my mind of offering a constructive
credit offering a problem that someone
perceived with your work and the point
is to get that problem fixed before it
goes how to communicate before it goes
out to be communicated to the real world
so we have two learning objectives in
this session first of all we're going to
overview what factors diminish the
reproducibility of published research
and at the end we'll talk about how
journals can promote reproducibility
through their publication requirements
so first to define reproducibility have
gone to the standard source of Wikipedia
for their definition and basically that
is the ability of an experiment or study
to be replicated either by the same
researcher or by someone else working
independently so reproducible research
refers to the idea that the publication
is the final product of the research
that is what is disseminated to the
public and it should provide all
information that's necessary to
reproduce the findings and build on them
and that can include not only animal
related details but also bench science
information the reagents that you used
for example if you're using database
work and you had doing database work and
you had to write code to analyze the
data the code should be available
basically anything that anyone would
need to your knowledge to reproduce what
is being done now the first stage of
reproducibility is within the pis lab
and it's fundamentally important that
whoever is doing a study should be
absolutely clear that they can
reduce their main finding this often is
not proof of this is generally not
demanded by reviewers it's generally
assumed that if you are submitting
something it is reproducible in your
hands and that the effect is strong
reliable and durable so we really i
think go on the assumption that if
something is submitted for publication
that the author is very confident that
they can replicate it in their own hands
I'm not sure how often though many
individuals really follow up on this one
time observation with a certain end may
be a game to deemed appropriate without
necessarily repeating an entire study to
make sure that what you've got can be
recreated in your hand so I think what
we're really talking about in terms of
publication is that we assume that the
information is replicable by the author
should also be replicated by other
replicable by others now this is not
always the case we have had at least one
instance in the ALS journals where a
group of fathers communicated to us that
they could not reproduce our original
finding and I really have to apply them
for that because they realize and
acknowledge that even though they
thought they had a sound finding that
huh it was it was not as substantial as
they expected it to be and in any case
notifying the field that there is an
issue that the authors don't understand
and cannot solve is an important step to
preventing resources from the moved into
a wrong direction so I think that that
kind of disclosure is is critical to
being sure that we don't waste resources
that are
available to us so some of these I'm
sure you've all heard of info before and
we'll go through them kind of quickly
because I think that these are factors
that will what we're all all well aware
of i will say first of all that in terms
of reproducibility of science it's not
just animal research that's the problem
many kinds of research many research
studies whether they're strictly in
vitro studies or extending to the human
realm are difficult to replicate and
that happens because we were doing
research we don't necessarily understand
everything that can impact the system
and take give a few to give an example
of this later but essentially we study a
system based on the knowledge that we
have at hand and if there are fat either
factors that we can't control or factors
that we don't even know about these may
influence research differentially as
different groups try to repeat the same
basic study so in many cases I don't
it's hard to put a number on it but
inability to replicate does not
necessarily imply that someone has done
something wrong it can also be that
there's something there that we don't
know about that influencing the system
under interrogation so this is an
important thing to think about when you
try to replicate someone study in can't
we don't know everything about the
system that we may need you alright so
moving on sand left here are our
experimental design factors you've all
heard of these incorrect group sizes and
i mighta say usually in my mind
inadequate group sizes you see in many
studies
the animal literature that are trying to
conserve animals sometimes to a level
that seems inconsistent with answering
the question that they that is being
asked and assuring that your group size
is appropriate is is really critical to
being sure that you have found
replicable phone data this may mean
repeating an entire study or it may mean
powering your study initially to be sure
that you can not miss porn not miss real
effects or that you do not over
interpret a small one time effect
control should be appropriate basically
you want to control for everything that
you can except for the one factor that
you are manipulating you want your
groups to be identical and this is
perhaps easier said than done the for
some reasons we'll talk about later but
maintaining your animals isn't strict
parallel circumstances throughout the
portions of this study is really
important blinding and randomization two
groups are also common problems blinding
is important particularly I would say
with regard to subjective assessments of
outcomes and so if you are using a study
in which are somehow it evaluating your
animals for pain or some other type of
subjective assessment that having the
observers be blinded to the condition of
the animal is really important
randomization is something that I think
is less emphasized in animal studies but
maybe should be and you have a tendency
when we're doing experiment to ran to a
fine animals to groups based on which
ones we pick up in the cage and doing
that make
did an unintentional bias if some of the
members of the group are more active
more mobile harder to catch easier to
catch so if you use a systemized
randomization scheme that can be avoided
and also for all statistical and
experimental design questions you should
plan in advance what you're going to ask
of the data and how you are going to
analyze the data and that that is really
fundamental you can't fish for
significant statistically speaking you
should shouldn't go fishing for
significant results unless they are part
of your experimental design with
pre-planned questions and pre-planned
analyses other factors that diminish the
reproducibility of animal research were
probably well aware of a lack of housing
and husbandry details the information
that's necessary to identify the source
of the animals and their various
characteristics and where when and who
the procedures were performed and this
type of information is i would say
particularly salient because there have
been a number of studies out there where
individuals at groups in various
laboratories have absolutely tried to
standardize everything they could with
regard to how the study was done and
then performed studies that were
attempting to replicate traits that they
found in various strains of mice and
were able to replicate some of the
effects but not all of the effects so
clearly even in very experienced
laboratories who understand and
appreciate all of these sources of
variation it's still hard to determine
what the factors are that are really
influencing the behavior or perhaps the
physiology of the animals you're
studying and a good example of this was
revealed perhaps last year or the year
before
no go lab which does ping research and
they presented the very amazing really
and well documented report stating that
the sex of the technician who performed
test procedures had an outcome on the
pain response of the animals that is if
his males perform the procedures male
researchers perform the procedures the
test procedures the mice showed
stress-related analgesia that was not
present his female performed the
procedures so there's a case of
something that probably we hadn't none
of us had ever thought out as a factor
in some of the testing but in fact when
is fair very observant and highly
experienced group of scientists did this
study they were able to notice that bias
in their data so I think I just
illustrates how careful you can be and
how you can overlook things that may be
important in replicability not through
necessarily lack of attention to detail
but simply by not knowing what kinds of
things the animals that were working
with will respond to okay sample size
and group size is there is a really
important issue that I shall we have
undervalued in animal research in human
research power analysis and a
predetermination of group sizes is just
the expectation the basic expectation of
what is going to happen but in animal
work we typically at least in many
places seem to overlook that including
in by presenting the power analysis and
publication and that's something that I
think we can rectify or demand either as
animal carry news communities that are
approving these studies or as
when a publication site is requiring a
power analysis to justify group sizes
and this is really critical you see some
very complicated studies out there that
have very low numbers of animals per
group and with those few animals in the
many variables that are being measured
it seems pretty clear that sample sizes
are inadequate another important thing
to consider is whether the experimental
unit is the whole cage or an individual
animal within the cage so if you have a
group of five and they're all in the
same cage the problem is that if
something happens to that cage you can
influence that cage and bias the
outcomes based on which group that cage
of animals belongs to so for example if
you have one cage that's your
experimental group and that cage happens
to experience a water leak or there's a
lot of fighting in that cage or maybe
there's some clinical illness in that
cage that can bias the outcome toward
animals in that cage and give you an
outcome that is dependent on some factor
rather than what you're trying to test
and if all your animals are in the same
cage for one group that that's really a
problem and then you're your number your
n might be not five animals but one cage
or however many cages you've assigned to
that condition so sometimes it's hard to
work with that within the confines of
space and cost but it is a really
important Avenue for biasing the data
and I will also say that I think this
also applies to bench work in many cases
when you do bench work and you run a
triplicate if you run your triplet
coding series you're going to have a lot
less variability than if you run them
randomly throughout your plate and
this kind of variability is something
that our potential for variability is
something that's not generally in my
experience much and only recognized or
acknowledged so running your triplicates
in syriza's is definitely going to make
your my hands anyway it's going to make
your values tighter than they might
otherwise be okay we've really talked
about this in some way about controls
and randomization certainly for
randomization you can use a random
number series 2 assigned group numbers
two treatment groups for subjective data
and blinding you have to ask the
questions of not only will the person
interpreting the data or generating the
data be blinded to stay groups but is
one rater enough and if you have more
than one Raiders how are you
establishing uniformity across
generators and there are approaches to
doing this that should be followed to
supply some not only to animal research
but also to any type of qualitative
research when you're evaluating
subjectively in a qualitative manner of
having multiple raters and documenting
uniformity across Raiders should be
established and as you can see this done
I mean I'm longer too long ago I
remember one example where we had a
group of surgeons and services the
surgeons and the surgery residents who
were evaluating and dhasku p photograph
and they established a scale for how
they were going to evaluate the severity
of the lesions that they were observing
and tested themselves and even the
individual who generated the scale got a
Porsche or so was not even replicating
himself so being sure that you have
established the score
where you're a scoring system where your
raiders are equivalent or can be tested
it is is really important for making
sure that your data the data you collect
are valid for housing and husbandry
factors that are are fundamental to
replicable research are the frequency of
housing whether the animals or group
housed are singly housed what types of
enrichment are provided of course the
food water bedding in cage type and even
where the mice were housed in the room
or on a rack can have an insolence
partly because environmental conditions
can change lighting conditions can be
different so a ventilation might be
different a lot of factors of that type
influence how the the animals find to
study can react to either the
experimental with control condition the
fourth bullet they are cage type I think
we've been recently really received a
lot of good data on that point from the
studies of log ouchie and Melissa trim
who have shown that cage types cade
color or tent significantly influences
some physiological parameters in the
mice house in the cage and if you are
from its facility that uses colored
cages or that even worse uses keep
colored cages at random for different
groups of animals you may be introducing
variability and a sense of your
reproducibility into the study
enrichment I i believe is something that
should be very carefully monitored and
standardized and reported to the
environment of the animal for the
duration of the study should be
controlled one of the big advantages of
using animals in research is that we can
control their environment and enriching
their environment is fine but it should
be done in a standardized reproducible
way that is reported in the publication
because there are many studies out there
that show that enrichment definitely can
influence the physiological or
behavioral spawn responses of the
animals and if your readers don't know
what you have done or even worse if you
don't know what you have done it may be
very difficult to reproduce that type of
an environment in terms of single versus
group housing you can run into the issue
of beginning with group housing and then
as the say proceeds animals drop out
that clearly changes the environment
within the cage for the animals that are
remaining and so that is another issue
that should be considered when you're
designing a study the description of the
animals you've mentioned a number of
things here that I think probably many
listeners are familiar with a strain
designation is the one that I will
mostly emphasize and because our genetic
backgrounds are getting more and more
complicated and the appropriate
nomenclature is just essential I
personally had a circumstance where I
had submitted a paper for publication
and I uniformly refer to the animals
that I used as Belle g ey j and one of
the reviewers of my paper asked why i
didn't use that designation throughout
the discussion and that was because many
of the papers that i read just said belt
c and so I could not extrapolate if they
were using
the same source of animals as I was
you're not and as many of us know that
can have an impact on the outcomes
strains strains of animals even inbred
strains that you get from different
vendors can clearly have different
genetics genetic dressed and so it's
important to know about that the genetic
manipulations also can interfere with
the reproducibility of research if the
genetic background influences the
research outcomes and there has been an
idea propagated that using a mixed
genetic background is a good thing and
in some circumstances it may be but
remember the point of this research is
to control everything you can point of
animal research is to have as much
control as you can on the animal and if
you are going to allow variations in
health status or variations in genetic
status or variations in housing into
your studies that is going to in fact
impact your outcomes in ways that you
probably can't predict experimental
procedures time of day that the sample
was collected or the behavior was
observed this is amiss can be really
critical as there can be large changes
due to securing circadian variations in
various measurements or behaviors and
then other experimental procedures that
I've mentioned here source does on route
of agents that you administer how you
monitor for effects and how you define
the subjective scales I see that I'm
using a lot of time so I'm going to try
to speed up here a little bit statistics
i already mentioned should be
pre-planned with pre-planned questions
power analysis and a plan for data
analysis
and in my mind it is always important to
include a statistician on the research
team others as part of the design phase
and as part of the analysis I also would
urge everyone to try to evaluate
biological as opposed to simply
significant statistical significance so
if you have a value and it goes from low
to lower maybe it's statistically
significant but is that biologically
meaningful that is worth some
considerations not really a point of
reproducibility but it may be a point
relevant to the significance of this
work that you're studying now I will add
to that what I've heard from can't
remember where I got this quote but from
a statistician if you torture the data
long enough it will admit to something
so if you design your study properly you
should not have to torture the data you
should find the result that you are find
or not find the result that you're
looking for in the context of your
immediate tongue and your fundamental
experimental questions and experimental
design so in terms of reproducibility
this can be aided by clear publication
requirements as I mentioned earlier even
as we review manuscripts for the a last
journal if we assume that they are be
replicable by the submitting officers
and we really require evidence of a
validation study and I think that is
generally true in my mind the
responsibilities there are lies with
mentors largely that mentors should have
high standards to impart to their
trainees in terms of habits and
practices that they teach their trainees
are adequate for performing valid
research high standards in mentors are
really important than it
hard to say hard for me to say anyway
whether that's a problem or not but I've
certainly seen at least some instances
where it seems to be a problem journals
can promote reproducibility by requiring
a complete method section in which
regard to animal research is probably
typed I would say the arrived guidelines
which maybe you all have heard of and
these supply this guideline supplies a
very focused and thorough list of
factors that i have reviewed and other
factors that should be considered in
developing a method section over the
past years in method section development
for scientific publication i would say
there's been a tendency to diminish the
importance of the methods section and
put it at the end or put it in an
appendix or put it somewhere where it's
not obvious but to me that it that is
really a strange attitude because how
can you really understand the paper if
you don't understand their methods it's
just fundamental to collecting the data
and knowing how to interpret the data so
it is not a cut and paste type of
activity in my mind it's something that
really needs to be thoroughly vetted
from all perspectives if you didn't know
the method could you repeat it based on
what's in that article and it's a less
journals we have preference to the
arrive guidelines for authors and for
reviewers so we we hope that those are
helpful and so finally let me just point
out that the real peer review starts
after publication we attempt to provide
peer review as part of our review
process or the journals and their
articles but we are not the
we are not the end of the process the
publication is where the peer review
starts when people try to replicate your
work and can or can't or look at your
work and find flaws that then reflect on
on you and on your science so I would
just encourage you to remember that the
peer review process for publication
helps you to avoid problems with peer
review that will occur after your work
is released and this is a very critical
service that I think should not be
viewed negatively in most cases so with
that I will stop and see if sue has
anything she wants to add and then we'll
take questions um what I would like to
say is there's really you really can
never put too much in the methods so if
you think that there's something that's
important for somebody reproduce it put
it in there no something doesn't have to
give you a list of what needs to be in
there everything you think that was a
variable and don't be afraid to say
something went wrong during the
experiment that there was an unexpected
outcome because you had you know a
series of fire alarms or you had a
series of water bottle accidents or
there was an outbreak down the hall and
you had a treat with ivermectin or
something else put all of that in the
methods because you don't know when you
write it if there's going to be a
variable or if somebody else is going to
recognize that as a variable that
they've seen before and say well they
saw this and I saw something similar
when we had the same problem all of
those things are helpful when somebody's
trying to interpret your study
great thank you both thank you both this
is there anything else you want to
continue to talk about with your
audience or should we have some
questions I think we're ready for
questions awesome let me just remind our
audience after this presentation on how
they can submit their questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
green Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we're going to try to get to as many of
your questions as possible but again I
thank both dr. taupe and dr. Compton
farakka such a great presentation it
really does speak to how much is
involved in creating your studies so
that they are worthwhile to your
community I'm going to give our audience
just a few seconds to bring up the Q&A
box typing in any questions that they
might have and we'll get on that and
don't be shy good doctors toes and compn
definitely want to hear from you and I
would say if you have any questions
related to publication in the a life
journals we'd be happy to take those as
well that's great i'm sure with this
group here there's probably a lot of
studies going on and knowing exactly how
to have those come up for a review is is
important for our audience
anybody out there there must be someone
who has a question or something we can
help you with really if you are let me
let me see here we do have one question
coming in well do you find that there
are problems with animal use common and
submitted manuscripts is just a common
occurrence for you so would you like to
comment what was the question again with
it are there problems with animal use
common in submitting manuscripts we
don't see an awful lot of problems in
the a lash journals because most people
are very knowledgeable about working
with animals I'm more likely to see it
in more categorical science journals
where there is not a lot of information
in on the animal methods and it's more
frequent to see you know people
abbreviating strain names and other
things of that nature and not
understanding that you know animals are
a complex organism and not the same as
working with a cell line and it's the
people who are transitioning that
sometimes don't understand and put
enough methodological details into their
paper but most people who work with
animals every day don't seem to have
that problem wait and you have our
reviewers are very good at catching his
omissions as well so you know basically
I think that in the ALS journal three we
tend to cover a lot of that information
there was a study someone did a study
last year that they gave a poster for at
payless where they did evaluate two or
three years of publications in thinking
j less about animal use and how we
complied with the arrive guidelines and
I don't remember the exact data I'm
hoping they will publish that as a full
manuscript but basically I think we did
okay not everything we
capture everything that was in the
arrive guidelines but had ahead of their
very reasonable report card on that is
that your remembrance in that too as
well yes great we have another question
from the attending as editors how do you
look at studies that have negative
results results often these are not
published yes i would say that we
publish many negative results because
many of the studies that we publish
particularly in jail s deal with testing
various regulatory guidelines and
demonstrating whether they produce an
impact on the animal that's different
from other conditions so basically i
would say we we publish a lot of studies
that find no difference between one
situation in another situation sorry we
r do gray suit i agree i think because
we're trying to get basing information
on how to best use animals most studies
whether they're positive or negative
will add to information that can be used
by other veterinarians by aya cooks and
other things of that nature so i think
we're more willing than some of the
other journals to publish either way and
i think the most important thing there
is not whether the results are negative
or positive whether it's an important
question and so if it's a research
question many people are an animal use
question generally that people are
struggling with having data to show that
something does not make a difference can
be very beneficial right you have
another question are there any specific
recommendations related to research with
zebra fish
Pacific I am NOT personally I don't know
i think that the general practice you
know the general requirements for
publication in a method section are very
similar certainly fish are going to have
different environmental requirements
then than other types of animals but as
far as describing thoroughly the
environment and the experimental
approach and I think dodges in general
very similar we don't publish a huge
amount of publications on zebrafish and
in general um you know we would ask for
the same kind of information so that we
would know no on all of the husband
green housing and handling kind of
information that was used in that study
probably the you know environmental I
don't the environmental controls the
Quality Assurance factors for zebra fish
are maybe an area that has not been as
well developed if it has been formed so
that might be an area where health
assessment and quality assurance could
use some work to get some of you some
ideas for if I have publishing are doing
research and publishing information I
don't think there are a lot of strong
guidelines out there at least not in the
published literature for the that I'm
familiar with us to how to provide that
kind of quality assurance great moving
on to our next question one of our
attendees desk I apologize that I only
heard the last half of the presentation
perhaps just has been addressed but
should the info presented today compel
our scientific societies to establish
details SOPs for consider conducting
some of the more common studies in their
fields to help reproduce to help reduce
variability across
different investigators and institutions
etc that's almost a philosophic question
you know I believe that certainly there
there may be preferred ways to doing
things that I personally am not too
inclined to stifle scientific ingenuity
by putting too many controls on what
people how people design their
experiments and what they do if there
can be some standardization then that
doesn't so that there's no really wrong
side to that but as far as making it
requirements how we just have to think
very carefully about something like that
my call would be more to have clear
reporting rather than clear requirements
you get that answer your own right maybe
I didn't quite get the question we do
have another question moving on to what
are some effective ways to include the
negative results which you mentioned can
be useful for future studies in a way
that does not prevent the acceptance of
the manuscript by reviewers
you have to present the information in a
way that shows that the negative result
is useful you know negative results can
be very useful for example if you
compare two diets and you find no
difference or if you compare to cage
sizes and you find their difference in
animal well-being that could be very
useful information so what's important
is not that it's negative data is that
the question is an important one and the
answer is useful no matter which way it
turns out okay we have another question
what are the most common reasons for
rejection of submitted articles do we
like I think the most common is um
having a poor experimental design so
having a sample sizes too small or
possibly extending the conclusions
beyond the data so essentially having
data that doesn't really show results
and trying to try to say there is a fact
or saying that the effect you know is is
applicable to all animals when all you
worked with was a 57 blackmail and so
you need to make sure that your
conclusions are are not overreaching and
also if you keep you have to make sure
that when you're looking and saying
something has a significant effect if
it's not statistically significant it's
not really significant and that probably
means that your sample size was too
small and so saying there's a trend
towards something means you should
probably run a file follow-up experiment
with a larger sample size to see if the
effect is true okay thank you
next question what should i do if i
cannot reproduce published research well
the first thing that i would suggest
it's research that you published you
should contact the journal and we will
publish as a letter to the editor that
you explain to the research communities
that you tried to reproduce your own
work and you are unable to do it for
unforeseen reasons and to me that is a
good way to maintain integrity and the
scientific method if it's published by
someone else to the person to contact is
the research group and see whether you
are really replicating or if something
is missing from their publish trees at
the published methods section that you
were trying to replicate that that's
really the best step is to just make
sure that you have covered all your
bases in terms of decide what you are
doing is exactly equivalent to what was
done in the published work though I
would also keep in mind that as I
mentioned earlier there are many subtle
influences on animal based research and
we don't always know what their
magnitude is or how they kind of expect
the let's say unknown variables to
influence outcomes so if you have
something that you have tried to
replicate and you can't that's not
necessarily a non publishable finding I
think it is a place where we need
perhaps more research to find out what
the forces that variation is okay thank
you for
that is another question from an
attendee about the amount of information
in the animal section he asked can all
of this information be in one paragraph
no I don't think one paragraph would do
it but we we don't have any limitation
to article sizes in our journals at
least so that might not be true for
every journal but in a less journals you
can put as much detail in there as you
would like to it's not uncommon in the a
lash journals for the materials and
methods to be longer than the results
that's very true right okay I think that
is all the questions that I've seen
coming in into the QA I would like to
thank doctors tote dr. Compton for
making this presentation possible and
for bringing their information to us
today doctors would you have any left
final comment for our audience on your
topic well I guess I'd go back to my
last slide the real review starts after
you publish and all I would say keep
that in mind and try to try to view your
critique of your manuscripts has the
first step in preventing
misunderstanding between what you
published and what you meant to say I'd
say that planning the experiment is as
important is analyzing it afterwards if
it's well planned the analysis a lot is
a lot easier to do great thank you both
so much also like to thank Laberge com
for making this panel discussion
possible today it's LZ landing again as
well to our moderator we we are happy to
be here bring this information to you
it's going to be available on demand
through August of 2016 in case anybody
wasn't able to come in and listen life
attendees will receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay and we
would invite you to forward that email
to any of your colleagues who may have
missed today live discussion thank you
again for joining
thank you dr. Todt dr. compn we hope to
see you next time thank you thank you
thank you